what will people in lafayette be doing
for the fight i'm not sure i know some
people are going to bars
um is there anything big plan is good
fight doing anything we were thinking
about trying to get a restaurant like we
did uh
for this last fight we just haven't
locked anything down yet we just uh
put together a big thing with the boys
and girls club of acadiana oh really
yeah we're doing a big thing with them
actually
um next year or this year 2021 we're
doing uh
tutors for all of their six locations oh
wow uh for the year because you know
social distancing and the learning kids
at home
you know it's it's been a mess so we're
going to help them get tutors
to the children's homes and also
transportation to and from the boys and
girls clubs for the year for the kids oh
gang
yeah yeah so i'm pumped about that the
good fight foundation is doing that and
then
connor's donating some money to the good
fight foundation and we're going to open
up a gym
in lafayette for really for the children
yeah yeah yeah
dude that's awesome so it's just for
kids or is it for white belts also
they're adults
we're going to do better near 40. nah
we're going to do kids
like uh in school but i have a gym there
dude you're always welcome with my gym
did you have beginner's classes
uh no but my buddies jim does oh he does
yeah yeah yeah
my gym is kind of like just a private
gym we just do pro training there
but my buddy has a beginner jiu jitsu
classes and stuff dude i'd love to jump
in one if you if you're back in time
dude that'd be awesome yeah
i'll put the key back on you would you
rather maybe it's been a while i haven't
put a gear on in a while
so so so you the training that you do is
different than
like the classes and stuff you're just
you're training with fighters
yeah mostly some sometimes i'm working
just with jiu jitsu instructors if we're
working on things
but uh beginning of my career even as a
pro beginning my pro career i would do a
lot of ghee
and stuff because i was in louisiana i
didn't have as much classes to choose
from i didn't have as many pro fighters
around me so
i would substitute training sessions in
regular classes because that's all i had
you know i had to learn
oh you see four kids fighting in a
remedial reading class in [ __ ]
vermillion parish yeah and then i'd ask
him to drill that
how do you do that again that's how i
learned yeah
some guy is beating the vowels into
somebody yeah yeah they're getting ar
reader points and stuff
yeah but uh yeah but it's been a while
i've done a
just like a jiu jitsu class oh yeah man
i've been choked out so many times last
month
um it's awesome yeah it's good it's fun
man
right dude it's so much fun i never knew
how like
i leave out of there dude and i [ __ ]
hope a cop pulls me over
yeah you know yeah because i know it's
gonna [ __ ]
be me or him one of us gotta go yeah
yeah
i just leave out of there feeling
[ __ ] different dog you know yeah like
the guy when i get to the gas station he
[ __ ] knows i'm using my
he knows i'm paying card and he knows
i'm in and out yeah yeah
everybody i just feel like you start to
get a different little bit of confidence
you get a different family too because
it's like you know you you don't realize
how big the subculture of jiu jitsu is
unless you're in into it but like you
start training and you get friends and
stuff at the gym and then you start
going to competitions or talking about
jiu jitsu with them and then you go to
barbecues and then you're like [ __ ] this
is my friends now you have a whole new
set of family really at the gym
that's what happened to me yeah yeah i
was like damn like these are my these
are my family and friends now
you know just from training with them
yeah yeah dude i go to this restaurant
and i go in there and two of the guys
from the uh mma class in nashville are
both work there
one of them oh does the oysters this guy
on hell dude he's [ __ ] kimoro
kamor in these oysters back there dude
he [ __ ] got a crab leg and he's got
it in a [ __ ] i need some moisture
marcellus choke you know yeah
[ __ ] interesting yeah but um yeah and
one thing i noticed like just my
confidence like
i've only been like maybe 15 classes so
i'm let's don't get
you know don't anybody come at me but um
but i noticed just like i used to feel
like if i got in the fight somebody was
gonna beat me up but i would also be
scared at the same time
now i just feel like somebody's gonna
beat me up
right i don't feel like i'm also going
to be scared yeah that's and that's good
that's growth so it's yeah it's just
crazy i never i always like oh [ __ ] dude
because it would suck to get beat up and
be being scared at the same time yeah
yeah and then the longer you do it the
next step i think is everything starts
to look like a lapel
like really well this guy's shirt he
wore a [ __ ] jacket today
cross choke you with that yeah
everything starts to look like a lapel
oh this guy's got long eyelashes
i'm gonna choke this guy with his
mustache oh yeah
everything is a weapon i'm just sitting
on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been